what does it mean to be here getting
this this beautiful retrospect of your
entire career what it means a mold Brad
Pitt you're like a fine wine getting
better with time I don't know thank you
though the once upon a time in Hollywood
star hit up the Santa Barbara
International Film Festival on Wednesday
where he received the prestigious Multan
modern masters award an award that
celebrated Brad's contribution to film
over the past three decades what does it
mean to be here getting this this
beautiful retrospect of your entire
career and do you think you've mastered
the acting thing at this point what it
means I'm old
it means I'm it's nice for me I've been
spending a lot of time here since 1999
so it feels homey for me my kids spend a
lot of time out here friends a lot of
time out here so that feels nice I don't
know I haven't done one of these things
before so we'll go see what happened and
of course we just had to ask Brad about
this backstage moment from the SAG
Awards yeah you know the moment I'm
talking about the moment Brad and
Jennifer Aniston reunited smiled at one
another touched hands and damn near
broke the internet award season has been
so fun what do you make of our reaction
to the big reunion backstage last week
at the set you don't know I'm blissfully
naive and I'm gonna stay that way yeah
I'm not so sure I believe him but I do
like Brad's I'm chill about the whole
thing attitude while the rest of us are
here losing our freakin minds everyone
is waiting they're hoping for this
moment where you and Jennifer run into
each other so they can take their
picture run into Jen she's a good friend
the second most important reunion every
of her year plan friends and then they
were saying that anyways it's hysterical
but what else are they gonna talk about
anyway back to Brad and his big award
and feeling old AF wow it's things like
this and that nights like these that
tell me I'm old
I've been around a while I've been doing
this a bit yeah I mean I la yeah like I
can't stand night shoots anymore
I'm gladly hand a stunt over to a
stuntman I no longer remember the first
rule of Fight Club director David
Fincher who worked with Brad on movies
like seven Fight Club and The Curious
Case of Benjamin Button presented the
honor to the a Lister that's so damn
funny if you if you could hear the way
we rip on each other weekly that was so
kind that was so nice he's never said
that to me ever
and Burt and Brad did what Brad does
graced us with humour and humility but
it's also nights like this where you
know I get to look back and and if you
really really blessed I feel so
fortunate to to to all the amazing
people I've been able to work with I
feel grateful for this I mean I love you
anyway you can count on me to bring you
all the latest on Brad Pitt so make sure
to keep it locked right here until next
time I'm Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]